Kvantové provázání umožňuje částicím být propojeny bez ohledu na vzdálenost mezi nimi – to je tak neintuitivní,
že ani Einstein tomu nevěřil. V dnešní epizodě Qiskit v učebně si povíme, jak Bellův
teorém dokázal, že Einstein
se mýlil. Vítej v Qubitu v učebně. V této sérii budeme používat Qiskit k prozkoumání některých základních konceptů běžně
probíraných v kurzech souvisejících s kvantovým výpočetnictvím. Každé video bude také doprovázeno interaktivním modulem
odkazovaným v popisu níže, takže ho určitě zkontroluj. Ve videu o kvantových mincích jsme diskutovali o tom, jak měření
kvantové superpozice je ze své podstaty pravděpodobnostní proces – v jistém smyslu jako hod mincí. Ale jak to víme?
Mohlo by to být tak, že kvantová částice tajně skrývá předem určený výsledek měření, ale my tuto informaci nějak nedokážeme
zachytit v naší teorii? V počátcích kvantové mechaniky byla tato otázka předmětem
bouřlivých debat se dvěma hlavními tábory. V jednom táboře byl Einstein, který věřil, že kvantová mechanika je neúplná –
tedy že jí chybějí nějaké proměnné nezbytné k úplnému popisu systému. Einstein si myslel, že tyto
takzvané skryté proměnné, pokud by byly nalezeny, by vyřešily některé zdánlivě paradoxní a pravděpodobnostní
aspekty kvantové mechaniky. V druhém táboře byl Max Born. Born tvrdil,
že pravděpodobnostní popis daný kvantovou mechanikou je vše, co příroda specifikuje – jinými slovy
nejde jen o to, že neznáme stav částice před jejím změřením, ale že částice před měřením žádný definitivní stav nemá.
Po desetiletí si mnozí mysleli, že tento spor je filozofickou otázkou, která možná nikdy
nebude vyřešena. Koneckonců, abychom se cokoliv dozvěděli o systému, musíme ho změřit. Jak se tedy vůbec můžeme dozvědět
cokoliv o povaze stavu před jeho měřením? Pak v roce 1964 fyzik
John Bell našel způsob. Ve svém článku Bell zkoumal statistické korelace mezi měřeními páru
provázaných částic. Pokud by stavy částic před měřením byly určeny nějakými neznámými skrytými
proměnnými, Bell zjistil, že jejich korelace mají horní limit. Na druhou stranu, když vypočítal
korelace předpovídané kvantovou mechanikou, zjistil, že tento limit porušují. Tak našel způsob, jak jednou
provždy rozlišit mezi Einsteinovým a Bornovým pohledem. Zbývalo jen skutečně experimentálně
otestovat tyto korelace na reálných částicích – zjistit, zda dodržují statistiku skrytých proměnných, nebo ji
porušují. Tyto testy byly prováděny s rostoucí přesností a sofistikovaností
v průběhu let a patří k nejvýznamnějším experimentům moderní fyziky. Byly natolik průlomové, že
třem fyzikům vynesly Nobelovu cenu v roce 2022. Dnes však může Bell test provést každý –
potřebujeme jen trochu znalostí Qiskitu a přístup ke kvantovému počítači IBM. V tomto videu tě
provedu logikou Bellovy nerovnosti a pak ti ukážu, jak můžeme Bellovy předpovědi testovat na kvantovém počítači IBM.
Bellova nerovnost zahrnuje několik různých měření a vrstev logiky, a může být trochu
obtížné ji sledovat, ale projdeme ji krok za krokem a na konci to stojí za to. Chystáme se ukázat,
že provázání je reálné a Einstein se mýlí – to není něco, co dokáže říct mnoho lidí. Takže zde je
to, co Bell navrhl: řekněme, že máš způsob, jak vyrábět mnoho kopií provázaného páru částic. Fyzikálně
mohou být tyto páry produkovány rozpadovým procesem, kde jedna částice se rozpadne na dvě. Pokud jsi sledoval video o
Stern-Gerlachově experimentu, víš, že částice mohou mít vnitřní moment hybnosti, zvaný
spin. Řekněme, že jedna částice se spinem nula se rozpadne na dvě částice
se spinem 1/2. Každá z částic se spinem 1/2 může být naměřena s hodnotou spinu +1/2 nebo −1/2,
nazývané také spin nahoru nebo spin dolů. Protože se rozpadly z částice se spinem nula, musí se jejich spiny zkombinovat
tak, aby celkový spin byl nula. Takže pokud je jedna naměřena nahoru, druhá musí být
dolů a naopak. Tyto částice tvoří provázaný pár, který vypadá takto.
Pokud je tedy jedna naměřena nahoru, druhá je dolů a naopak. Řekněme, že částice 1 odletí doleva
neboli ve směru minus X, kde ji výzkumník Lucas změří
spin. Pak částice 2 podobně odletí doprava,
kde ji může změřit další výzkumník Rihanna. Lucas a Rihanna mohou nezávisle
otočit svá měřicí zařízení a zvolit si měření spinu svých příslušných částic podél libovolného směru
kolmého na směr pohybu částice. Pokud pošleme mnoho kopií provázaného stavu Lucasovi
a Rihanne, mohou shromažďovat měřicí statistiky. Pokud vždy měří podél stejné osy, tyto statistiky nebudou
příliš zajímavé – pokaždé, když jeden naměří spin nahoru, druhý naměří spin dolů, a pokaždé, když jeden naměří spin
dopředu, druhý naměří spin dozadu, a tak dále. Ale pokud dva výzkumníci měří podél různých os, můžeme zjistit
něco zajímavějšího. Dejmě Lucasovi a Rihanne tři osy, podél nichž
měří. Nazveme tyto osy a, b a c a jsou od sebe navzájem vzdáleny
o 120°. Otázka, kterou budeme s tímto experimentem zkoumat, je: pokud Lucas a Rihanna mohou měřit podél libovolné ze tří
os, jak často získají oba stejné znaménko? Jasně, pokud Lucas a Rihanna náhodou měří podél stejné osy –
řekněme osy a – nemohou nikdy získat stejné znaménko, protože se spiny musí zkombinovat na nulu. Ale když si vyberou
různé osy, jak budou jejich měření korelována, pokud vůbec? Podle Einsteina je tento kvantovomechanický
popis stavu částice neúplný. Myslel si, že musí existovat skryté proměnné, které předem určují výsledek všech možných měření spinu –
protože bez toho by provázané částice musely nějak okamžitě sdělovat výsledek svého měření jedna druhé. Pokud by jedna byla naměřena
nahoru tady, druhá by okamžitě musela vědět, že má být dolů
tamhle. Tyto skryté proměnné mohly být libovolně složitou sadou instrukcí pro výsledek experimentů, ale podstatné je,
že spinový stav každé částice je určen samostatně – takže žádná komunikace není nutná.
že spinový stav každé částice je určen samostatně, takže žádná komunikace není nutná.
Experimentálně by to znamenalo, že měření Lucase by neměla žádný vliv na Rihanninu částici a naopak.
To by mohlo klást určité limity na to, jak moc mohou být dvě měření korelována. Podle Borna ale tento stav
psi je vším, co lze o páru částic říci před měřením – takže měření jedné částice
ovlivňuje výsledek měření druhé. To může mít odlišné důsledky pro korelace mezi měřeními. Podívejme se, jak každá
teorie ovlivňuje tyto korelace. V přístupu skrytých proměnných existuje tajná sada instrukcí před
měřením, která již určuje, co Lucas naměří podél každé ze tří os. Například tyto
instrukce mohou být: kladné, pokud Lucas měří podél osy a,
kladné, pokud měří podél b, a záporné, pokud měří podél c. Toto můžeme
zapsat jako plus a, plus b a minus c. Pak by Rihannina částice
potřebovala mít proměnné minus a, minus b a plus c, aby celkový
spin podél libovolného jednoho směru byl nula.
Existuje osm sad možných instrukcí, které splňují toto omezení nulového spinu. Takže pokaždé, když je nový pár
částic zaslán Lucasovi a Rihanne, může obsahovat kteroukoli z těchto osmi sad instrukcí. Nyní chceme
zjistit – za předpokladu, že částice obsahují jednu z tajných sad instrukcí uvedených v tabulce, a
za předpokladu, že Lucas a Rihanna si každý nezávisle zvolí, podél které ze tří os měřit – jaká je
pravděpodobnost, že oba naměří stejné znaménko? Pokud jsou instrukce z řádků 1 nebo
8, pak je tato pravděpodobnost zřejmě nula, protože dvě částice budou mít opačná znaménka bez ohledu na jejich
měřicí osy. Ale co instrukce v řádku 2? Stejná znaménka by naměřili, pokud
by Rihanna měřila podél c a Lucas podél a nebo b, nebo pokud by Lucas
měřil podél c a Rihanna podél a nebo b. To jsou čtyři z devíti
možných kombinací měření, které dají Lucasovi a Rihanne stejné znaménko. Pokud to uděláme pro
každou sadu instrukcí, uvidíš, že řádky 3 až 7 také dávají pravděpodobnost 4/9. To znamená, že pokud
má Einstein pravdu a skryté proměnné jako tyto předem určují výsledek měření, Lucas a
Rihanna nemohou nikdy naměřit stejné znaménko s pravděpodobností větší než 4/9. To je Bellova nerovnost: P menší nebo
rovno 4/9. A jak ukážeme, provázané částice ji porušují. Abychom viděli, co předpovídá kvantová mechanika,
řekněme, že Lucas měří podél a. Mohou nastat dvě věci: buď naměří spin nahoru, takže
Rihanna by naměřila spin dolů podél a, nebo naměří spin dolů a Rihanna by naměřila spin nahoru podél a. Ale
chceme pravděpodobnost, že Rihanna naměří stejné znaménko jako Lucas podél libovolné osy podle svého výběru, nejen podél a. Pokud
měří podél b nebo c, je to trochu složitější. Ukazuje se, že
pokud víš, co Rihanna naměří se 100% jistotou podél jednoho směru, můžeš vypočítat pravděpodobnosti,
že naměří nahoru nebo dolů podél libovolné jiné osy, s trochou geometrie.
Pokud tvůj stav vždy měří spin nahoru podél jedné osy, pravděpodobnost naměření spinu nahoru podél jiné osy
se rovná druhé mocnině kosinu poloviny úhlu mezi dvěma osami. To je trochu složité, ale
ukážu ti, co tím myslím. Pokud Lucas naměří spin nahoru podél a, víme s 100% jistotou, že Rihanna by naměřila
spin dolů, kdyby měřila podél a. Takže to můžeme znázornit vektorem
takto. V tomto případě jsou úhly mezi tímto vektorem a ostatními dvěma měřicími osami b a c oba
60°. Tedy polovina z toho je 30° a kosinus
30° je zde uveden. Kosinus na druhou
z 30° se rovná 3/4. Co kdybychom Lucas naměřil spin dolů
podél a? Víme, že Rihanna by naměřila spin nahoru podél a, takže zde můžeme nakreslit další vektor.
Tento vektor znázorňující tuto informaci je vzdálen 120° od každé ze dvou ostatních os b
a c. Takže můžeme použít stejný geometrický trik, ale tentokrát dostaneme kosinus
z 60°. Tedy kosinus na druhou
z 60° se rovná 1/4. Protože Lucas bude se stejnou pravděpodobností
měřit spin nahoru i spin dolů podél a, musíme tyto dvě pravděpodobnosti Rihanniných výsledků zprůměrovat. Dostaneme konečnou
pravděpodobnost, že Rihanna naměří stejné znaménko jako Lucas, rovnou 1/2. Takže P
se rovná 1/2. Polovina je větší než 4/9, takže Bellova nerovnost je porušena.
To znamená, že pokud platí pravidla kvantové mechaniky, skryté proměnné jsou nemožné. Nyní můžeme použít Qiskit a
kvantový počítač IBM k testování Bellovy nerovnosti s reálnými kvantovými měřeními. Můžeme namapovat stavy spin nahoru a
spin dolů Lucasových a Rihannin částic na stavy nula a jedna qubitů v kvantovém počítači. Vezmeme
dva qubity – jeden pro Lucasovu částici a jeden pro Rihanninu – a propojíme je tímto kvantovým circuit.
Dva qubity jsou tedy znázorněny dvěma vodiči q0 a q1 a tato kombinace
X, Hadamard a CNOT gate vytvoří stejný provázaný stav, jaký byl mezi Lucasovými a Rihanninými částicemi. Nyní
musíme změřit každý qubit. Lucasovo měření nastavíme podél a, o které řekneme, že je osa Z. Rihannino
měření pak může být podél a, b nebo c, takže budeme potřebovat tři samostatné circuit pro každý z těchto tří případů. Ale v tomto
videu uděláme jen jeden. Plnou verzi najdeš v modulu odkazovaném v popisu. Pokud Rihanna měří podél
b, pak náš circuit vypadá takto, kde Ry je rotace o 120° pro změnu
Rihanniny měřicí osy. Můžeme použít Qiskit Primitive sampler k mnohonásobnému spuštění tohoto experimentu a shromáždění
statistik z výsledných měření. Dva sloupce 0 0 a 1 1 představují případy, kdy Lucas a
Rihanna naměřili stejné znaménko, což nás zajímá. Pravděpodobnost naměření obou částic se stejným
znaménkem je velmi blízká 1/2. To porušuje Bellovu nerovnost. To znamená,
že dvě částice jsou provázány – každá z nich nějak zdánlivě okamžitě zná výsledek měření
té druhé. Stále existuje určitá neshoda ohledně toho, jak přesně toto
provázání interpretovat a co se děje, když změříš provázaný stav, ale tyto otázky jsou spíše filozofické.
Teorie je v tuto chvíli poměrně nesporná – provázání je rozhodně reálné a víme to díky Bellovi, jeho
nerovnosti a mnoha fyzikům, kteří provedli experimenty na její testování. Pokud chceš být počítán mezi tyto
fyziky a provést vlastní Bell test s kvantovým počítačem, určitě přejdi na modul Bellovy nerovnosti
odkazovaný v popisu. Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.